hey all you rock and roller teeny bopper hop sock
and kids your old music Maven here Michael Knowles
I have been asked to put all of my cultural and
musical expertise to the Forefront for a song
called girls like girls this is by the artist
Haley kiyoku it has 149 million views online
right now The Producers have not told me very
much about this video except I have to infer
from the song title is this this is a lesbian
thing guys okay something like that they tell
me all right well I bear no responsibility for
whatever sort of deviant Madness is going to
ensue but I will try to analyze this and in so
doing analyze our whole culture take it away
yeah
by the way in my experience girls hate girls
I have almost never met two women
who genuinely like each other
boys
scared to let your guard down boys
tell the neighbors I'm not
sorry if I'm breaking walls
that was the boyfriend not noticing this this
very bizarre tension between his
girlfriend and that other girl
they say the girl's sister Maybe
girls like girls like boys do nothing new
that's true lesbians have existed in the
popular imagination for all of human history
Aristophanes talks about this in the Symposium
that all people are born with their other half
out there for some people some boys the other
half is a girl some girls either half as a girl
some boys ever have as a boy that's an old idea
we could be everything that we would ever need
this is the sticking point and I suspect that
most people in our culture agree with this idea
even the conservatives the libs obviously do
who are promoting all this kind of stuff but the
conservatives I think accept this too and it's the
idea that men don't really need women and women
don't really need men I don't want to play with
you anymore when in fact one can have a good life
in consecrated celibacy one can have a good life
after the death of one spouse I'm not denying
that but men are made to be complementary to
women women are made as complementary to
men and men and women are not the same
that's the big divide in our culture right now
some people in our culture believe that men
and women are exactly the same that includes the
feminists that includes the gay rights activists
that includes the transgender activists that
includes the radical individualists they believe
that every person is not fundamentally a man
or fundamentally a woman or fundamentally even
a religious being but just fundamentally
an individual undifferentiated and then
the conservatives believe no we're actually born
into society not as just these kind of undefined
atoms but with a real shape with a body shape and
with a role and with a purpose and so we all have
purposes this this life the steers tumbler has the
purpose of bringing delicious salty leftist ears
into my mouth this microphone has the purpose
of transmitting the dulcer tones of my voice to
all of you out there in Internet land and our
bodies have a purpose too and a male body the
purpose of our sexual organs is for the opposite
sex and specifically for procreation within the
context of marriage for the good houses and the
generation and education of children but as that
goes away then we're left with this rather
shallow idea which is that you and I of the
same sex or whatever we can be everything that
we need but there is actually more to life than
just girls my 12 year old Michael might not have
accepted that statement that there's more to life
than girls but there actually is more life than
girls and there's more to life than just boys
there's more to life than just this and just that
actually we are made for one another and we can
complement one another not just merely reflect
ourselves and the other person right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles we all know
about the big wireless companies out there they
lock you into these horrendous contracts and if
you try to get out of them early they tack on
outrageous charges that is why I made the switch
to Pure Talk Wireless where there are no hidden
fees no contracts and no hassle pure talk to us
customer service team has helped so many people
make the switch in as little as 10 minutes you
are even able to keep your phone number Pure Talk
has a range of affordable plans to choose from
you can find the perfect option for your needs
unlimited talk text plenty of data just thirty
dollars a month their 5G service is super fast
consistent does not drop calls you can get the
same coverage you're used to at half the rate
that you're currently paying Pure Talk saves the
average family over nine hundred dollars per year
not only will you save money but you will also
get the satisfaction of knowing you're supporting
a great American company the CEO and chairman of
pure talk is a US military veteran when you become
a Pure Talk customer you are given the option to
support America's Warrior partnership which is an
organization that works to prevent veteran suicide
go to puretalk.com and to promo code and I'll save
50 5-0 off your first month puretalk.com promo
code knows Pure Talk is simply smarter Wireless
gotta get it with you
you gotta get with you the vision of the music
video is that boys are really terrible and they're
bullish and they're stupid and they're vulgar
and they're actually kind of abusive too and
they're gonna grab women and this does speak to
a serious aspect of lesbianism which is that I'm
not saying all girls who like girls that way but
for a disproportionate number of lesbians they
become lesbians after they suffer some kind of
sexual trauma at the hands of men so that part
that part is realistic but you can see how the
vision is totally skewed because in the vision
of the music video women are are made to have sex
with women and women are all great and men are all
terrible and there's no reason that any woman
would want anything to do with them keep going
nothing nothing new
boy
is that it be right now now the music's coming
back up oh here we go this is the kiss right
are you kidding me
oh yeah that's realistic this young younger
presumably and smaller girl is just beating
up this bigger guy right obviously there's a lot
of Fantastical thinking going on and imagery going
on in this music video but the most absurd of
all and you see this throughout the popular
culture is this idea that small little girls can
just by virtue of their own Brute Force beat up
much bigger guys that cannot happen that does
not ever happen and I talked to Millennials I
talk to Men Women everybody and they actually
believe what they see in the movies which is
that physically small little girls can just beat
up much larger guts that that is not realistic
actually this is one of the arguments for the
Second Amendment is it because men are much
physically stronger than women women need
something to equalize the playing field
if they're going to be out walking around alone
which would be a gun and to tell women otherwise
is just completely irresponsible and and
furthermore the idea that this boyfriend
would come out and just start feeding up these
women because they almost kiss first of all in
our depraved day and age the the boyfriend would
probably come out and get a kick out of it you
know he'd probably encourage it to happen but
furthermore uh that that's not the reaction the
guy the guy would probably be pretty peeved that
his girlfriend is kissing anybody else let alone
a woman or he might find it kind of titillating
and weird but the idea that the man would come
out and just start punching women that's absurd
that just that just is very unlikely to happen in
our culture but it does feed into The Narrative
of men bad women good that's why no one should
ever be attracted to man in any way especially
women because women are girls are made for girls
in the way that boys think that they are made
for girls but they're really not keep going
is
it's funny they they actually cover up the kiss so
they keep whenever they go in for a kiss they kind
of turn their heads or it's covered up by the hair
and it doesn't seem believable put a pause there
I don't mean just to criticize the acting of these
young ladies they're doing a fine job in the music
video but you can even see from the performance
this is unnatural whatever you want to say about
it okay I'm not delving into the entire issue of
lesbianism but it's not normal it's not natural
behavior and you see that reflected even in the
performance of it and even in the fact that the
director and cinematographer don't don't show
it totally head on they allude to it they kind
of cover it up with the hair then there's a hug at
the end because they know it's not the same thing
as when Prince Charming rides up on the White
Horse and whips up the Damsel in Distress and
plants a big smooch on her it's not it's different
because men and women are different doesn't know
nothing new nothing new that's true subversive
and Fantastical imagery is nothing new and it
is true that throughout all of human history
there have been eccentric expressions of our
sexual desires this is a fallen and
quirky world that is true but just
because something happens does not mean that
it is ordered to happen that way and that it
is necessarily something that one should aim
for or attempt to normalize the existence of
the abnormal is not an argument that that which
is normal I either is not normal or should not
be pursued girls might like girls but they do
not like girls like boys do see you next time